Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show, I am Ferren cousins from Ring of Fire,
sitting in for David Pakman today.
And don't forget, you can find me on YouTube,
YouTube, dotcom slash the ring of fire and
YouTube, dotcom and balanced.
We had a lot of movement over this past weekend
on the infrastructure bill, the slimmed down
infrastructure bill.
We still, of course, have reconciliation on
the other part, which unfortunately not going
so well.
But let's talk about what is kind of going
well at this point.
Senate did vote to move forward on infrastructure
negotiations, infrastructure debate, really
good.
Like I said, positive developments.
It looks like you are getting some Republicans
who are starting to come around to this.
Obviously, whatever happens in the Senate,
this thing still has to go through the House
of Representatives where it's going to go
through even more changes so far from over
at this point.
But we are seeing forward progress.
But there's somebody who is not happy about
forward progress, somebody who has been shouting
for two weeks now, that forward progress is
a bad thing.
And you guessed it, ladies and gentlemen,
that person is none other than former President
Donald J. Trump.
Trump issued a warning to Republicans over
the weekend.
He said Joe Biden's infrastructure bill is
a disgrace, will be very hard for me to endorse
anyone foolish enough to vote in favor of
this deal.
You know what I love about that statement?
It's such a small statement, OK?
It's so tiny.
It's just a little sentence, two sentences,
I guess, technically, but it says so much.
About American politics today, not just about
Trump, not just about the Republican Party,
but it says so much about politics.
So I have to break this statement down again,
this tiny little statement.
I'm breaking it down three different ways.
The first one is take off partizan blinders,
get rid of hatred for Trump, get rid of support
for infrastructure, all of that.
Let's just look at this as political strategy,
because what I'm going to say here might shock
you from a strategy standpoint.
Trump is right.
I know, I know it's weird to even say it,
but.
He's right.
What's the Republican's best chance to win
in the twenty twenty two midterms, showing
the public that the Democrats couldn't get
anything done, showing the public that all
these lofty goals of the Democratic Party
fell flat?
And of course, by doing that, they're going
to omit the part where they're the ones who
made it all fail.
That's how the talking point works.
But Mitch McConnell was very clear a couple
months ago when he said on camera, we've got
to make sure that they can't move forward
on their agenda because McConnell knows the
same thing.
They've got to make a pitch to voters because
so far all their attacks on Biden have failed.
That's another important thing to remember,
folks.
All their attacks have failed so far.
Because they don't have anything real to attack
him on, so if they give him this infrastructure
package, that is a big win for the Democratic
Party.
Not as big as it should have been, certainly
not as big as they were asking for in the
plan, but if the Democrats produce, if the
Democrats go to the public and say, we got
through this because remember, it's not just
an infrastructure plan, folks.
It is a jobs plan that is widely supported
by members of both parties out there in America.
So, again, this is only looking at this through
nonpartizan eyes, Trump saying, do not support
this.
That is what the Republicans would be doing,
except, of course, the other side of that
strategy.
And this is where Trump is totally wrong on
it.
As I just mentioned, majority of Republicans
out there support this hack, a majority of
Republicans even support raising taxes on
the wealthy and corporations to pay for it.
They supported it before it was even cut down
to one point two trillion.
They liked it when it was three and a half
trillion.
They want the plan.
So they would be less likely in turn based
on that, to believe Republican talking points
that Democrats were unable to deliver because
they're clearly paying at least somewhat attention
to this issue.
And that's another positive development.
They know who's holding this thing up.
They know that they want it and they know
that Republicans and to a degree mansion and
cinema don't want them to have it.
So that's why Republicans are stuck between
the rock and a hard place here on terms of
strategy, they want to get Democrats to lose,
but they can't have their voters who support
this bill know that they were the ones who
kept it from making it to them.
So I think at this point, some of them clearly
not all of them, but I do think some of them
have looked at this and said, you know what,
the best path forward for us is probably to
let this thing happen, at least, hey, maybe
then if there are some positive developments
out of it, once it passes, I can go back to
my constituents and tell them I supported
this thing.
I did this for you.
So that could likely be the strategy that
these people take moving forward.
And of course, there's also the third part,
and that is who cares if Trump withholds his
endorsement?
There was a study that came out last week
and I actually spoke about this on my other
channels because it's a phenomenal study and
I love it.
They looked at races where Donald Trump endorsed
the candidate versus races where Donald Trump
did not endorse a candidate and the political
scientists who looked at all of these endorsements
and all of the outcomes.
Came to a statistical conclusion.
That a Donald Trump endorsement.
Makes you two and a half percent less likely
to win your race, candidates who received
the Trump endorsement again, two and a half
percent, not two and a half times, two and
a half percent.
Less likely to win, so it's a very, very tiny,
tiny disadvantage, but it's a disadvantage
nonetheless.
And the report also did mention that know
when Trump endorses a candidate, they end
up raising a ton more money.
But you know who else does?
Their opponent, every time Trump comes out
and endorses somebody, they raise more money,
but so does their opponent.
They also found that voter turnout actually
does increase in races where Donald Trump
endorses a candidate.
But again, in most instances, it benefits
the opponent, not the person Trump endorsed.
So Trump wants to be the kingmaker.
He's out there pretending to be the kingmaker.
He's threatening them, trying to scare them
into submission, saying, I'm not going to
endorse you if you don't do this.
And Republicans need to respond with respond
with good like please don't endorse me.
In fact, could you endorse my primary opponent?
Because I really want to win this election.
And your endorsement at this point is effectively
a kiss of death.
You're not helping candidates, you're hurting
them, you're literally making things more
difficult for them, so don't come out there
acting like I'm going to withhold my endorsement.
Don't threaten us with a good time, man.
We have seen the numbers.
We know what the data looks like.
We know that your endorsement doesn't change
people's minds.
And when it does, it changes them in favor
of the other candidate.
So, again, Republicans, you're not actually
stuck between a rock and a hard place here.
You've got a pretty easy out vote in favor
of the infrastructure package, go back to
your constituents, tell them that you delivered
it for them, and give Donald Donald Trump
the finger on the way out the door, because
trust me, you don't want his endorsement unless,
of course, you're looking forward to early
retirement.
That would really be the only thing that would
work in your favor at that point.